yes i saw that there was one question
that was
hanging there but i only see a question
about this car i can answer that
offline that's fine
i answered a couple during the break all
right
all right okay good let's go awesome
all right thanks everyone um uh and feel
free to keep asking questions in the
q a um so what we were talking about
right before
was um thinking about starting to think
about the limitations
of important sampling estimators as well
as model
or model-free based estimators both of
which often could have asymptotic bias
so doubly robust estimators were these
ways to combine between these two
different types of estimators
and particularly at this nice property
that if you either had an accurate model
of say the value function or you could
estimate the behavior policy
consistently
then you could end up with consistent
estimators asthmatically
so i'll try to go through some of this
fairly quickly um
so that we have time to go through some
of the later stuff um
some of the work that we were really
curious about this within this was to
think about really focusing directly on
mean squared error
so that if our goal is to make accurate
estimates for the off policy setting
of trying to be able to evaluate this
target policy
could we try to more directly trade off
between variance and bias
and what we did in this work and um uh
is to
both uh propose a weighted doubly robust
estimator
um which combines sort of an important
sampling estimator and a model based
estimator
um and still does so in a way um well
i'll talk about the properties in a
second this often can be empirically
much better so i'll just highlight that
empirically
much better it introduces a little bit
of finite sample bias in return for huge
gains in s
and efficient variants which people also
are familiar with from weighted
important sampling which i know is
something i didn't get a chance to go
over in depth here
um the other thing we tried to do here
is sort of directly kind of trade off
between estimators that within a
trajectory could balance between like a
model based approach versus an important
sampling based approach
um and and the way we did this then is
to think about these different types of
estimators and try to directly estimate
their bias and their variance and then
use this as a way to trade off between
these different types of estimators
and i think sort of the beneficial thing
of this line of work was to
first show that these type of doubly
robust estimators for reinforcement
learning
that had been proposed recently by
others and then us
were in fact strongly consistent which i
think is always a nice property
to have which is as our data goes to
infinity
and and again i want to highlight here
that we're always assuming overlap
and sequential ignorability that you
would in fact converge
to to the real value of that policy um
and again for a lot of the domains that
i'm interested in we really care about
what those actual estimates are because
often those are going to be used to make
a decision about whether or not to
deploy something
the other thing i want to highlight here
is that there really can be a big
difference
in terms of data efficiency between
these different methods and i know right
now we live in the age of big data but i
think that there are many domains
um you could consider something like you
know advanced stage metastatic
breast cancer where we're just not gonna
fortunately we're not gonna have
trillions of people with that condition
but that doesn't mean those problems
aren't important and so
we're going to need statistical
efficiency in order to be able to tackle
some of those problems
and so what i just wanted to highlight
here even though the focus of this
tutorial is really more on the theory
side is to say that
if you look on the x-axis that's the
amount of data we have the number of
trajectories and then on the y-axis is
mean squared error
this is a grid world this is not you
know it's a sample toy problem but i
just want to highlight here that
the approach that we proposed which was
titled magic
was giving basically um could find an
equally accurate estimate with about 10
of the data and that's important because
in some of these cases we might only
have say
2 000 people with certain conditions or
might have small data sets
and so as we focus on statistical
efficiency that can really lead to
benefits
oh great question someone just asked you
know how do you choose a policy such
there is over
such there that there is overlap great
question hold on to that i'll come back
to it
super interesting question very
important okay
the other thing i just want to highlight
is that these types of estimators
i also had a question in the break about
what do you do you know empirically
you told us about a lot of different
estimators what should we do
um i think things like doubly it depends
on
your domain um i think for high stakes
applications
doubly robust weighted doubly robust
things that give you confidence
intervals are often really important
so this is a sepsis treatment example i
believe this is from the mimic data set
from some colleagues um this is not our
work
uh they found in this case so so often
we're going to be interested in trying
to evaluate the performance of an
alternative policy
and see if we have confidence that it's
doing better than a baseline
phil thomas has also done a lot of work
on this and the thing that i want to
highlight here
is that the estimator of the estimators
they looked at
the the only estimator that was both a
consistent
policy estimator that could also sort of
um identify that there was this better
policy than the physician policy
was our weighted doubly robust that
still makes the standard assumption no
confounding and we'll come back to that
i do want to highlight though that this
is not always the right answer so
there's
this nice paper by lee voloshano new
where they compare different estimators
in domains that
um may not be as high stakes and you are
pretty
um trading off robustness um and
efficiency
robustness for efficiency so what you
can see here is fitted q evaluation
which is this model free estimator we
talked about before
you can see with sort of a smaller
amount of data it already is able to get
closer to the true value
so if you're in cases where it doesn't
if you're not concerned about model bias
so much or or if it's not as critical to
be able to get a good estimate
of the policy maybe the stakes are lower
maybe it's easier to collect data
i think some of these other methods
which may have less rigorous
guarantees in all cases often you know
have a big benefit of being able to be
very very data efficient
i'll still argue that interestingly in
that in one of their recent papers um
this approach that we propose magic
still has state of the art performance
and some important settings and i think
they're not they have a nice
comparison both um this this is a nice
comparison of a number of different
estimators
and also sergey levine and colleagues
have a nice recent sort of survey of
offline
where they also sort of think about a
couple different types of methods theirs
is more focused on the dbrl setting
i think in general you can do a lot of
blending between important sampling
models
one thing that i did not talk about much
here which i think is
really interesting something during this
semester i'm curious to explore more
is that there's this other sort of line
of work from kind of econometrics and
statistics
that is really thinking of these these
things as nuisance parameters like these
model estimates or these behavior
policies
what we really care about is the value
of a policy and
there's been some really interesting
work coming out from like nathan kalis
and
his club radioera and some others
thinking about sort of some different
kind of in some ways objectives to try
to compare these different types of
approaches
most of those give asymptotic style
guarantees on efficiency
i want to highlight that in finite data
often the choices we make of which
models we use
are model-free function approximators
even if we're using doubly robust
methods
but that can still matter and there's
been several different papers including
from our group
that try to think about if you really
have a small amount of data
what's the best way to get those
estimates
but i guess i just want to highlight too
that i think that um
while there's i don't think this problem
is completely closed i feel like there's
been
a lot of really exciting work in this
space um
and i think to me um there's sort of a
lot of existing good estimators you can
use
for a given problem and i think there's
different ones that might be better
depending on whether
things are high stakes or not but i
think for many applications we have good
estimators that we could use if you care
just about
policy evaluation i think one of the
places where things are less settled
um is in off policy optimization so i'm
going to sort of segue into that now
so off policy optimization is this
question of we don't just want to look
at
a previous particular policy we want to
be selecting across
policies and one thing that i want to
highlight immediately is that
reinforcement learning has sort of these
different ways of viewing what the
process
is and we can sort of focus on you know
the models like the dynamics
and the reward model or we can
focus on a value function or we can
focus
directly on policies and so each of
these are sort of defining different
types of hypothesis classes we could be
searching over
and different choices might make
different sense in terms of
computational trade-offs
um or modeling trade-offs so there's
even this sort of question of
we want to talk about finding the best
how are we defining that and under what
conditions can we talk about there being
things that are the best
so the next thing
here is um and i thank someone for
mentioning that my video feed is off i'm
turning off mostly right now because i'm
writing a lot and so it probably just
leave me
as if i was giving a lecture and looking
down on writing um
but i'll try to turn it on when i'm
answering questions
so the first thing we do with off policy
optimization is similar to what we would
do for a policy evaluation which is
we can learn a dynamics and reward model
and then we plan
and so again we would just have a
simulator these sorts of approaches can
be
very effective and i'll talk more about
them uh when we get
to some of the sort of um very recent
styles of approaches
so this can be very effective um this
has the same problem with
kind of model bias and stuff um the
second thing we can do
is do fitted q iteration which is
very similar to q learning with a
function approximator
where we have you know like a bellman
equation
and we have a parametrized value
function so this is like
got some sort of this could be like a
deep neural network
or a linear value function or something
like that
and then we want to use this and we do
repeated rounds of um you know
an approximate sort of dynamic
programming style approach
there's been a lot of work on on this
type of approach
um and i want to again give you sort of
a flavor of the type of result that
people have got for this um
so i think one uh there's a nice recent
result from chen and zhang
um where they analyze the sample
complexity of fitted q iteration
and so it says given a data set d with a
particular sample size
and i'll just note here that sometimes
the sample size in terms of these kind
of like
state action reward next state tuples
and sometimes it's in terms of
trajectories
and then the assumption that the
function class satisfies
completeness and
and so what that means in this case is
that when you do this bellman backup
you're still in the space so when you
again if we think back to that
nice diagram from kind of sutton and
barto
you had a value function here
you do your belmont backup in general
that may not lie in the same space
what this assumption is saying
assumption three
is that in fact you have a situation
like this where you start in the
f and you stay in f after you do
the belmont backup and that certainly
will not always be the case but this is
you know that this is making that
assumption that you stay inside the
space
then with high probability after a
certain number of k iterations
um then the resulting value function you
get
its difference from the optimal value
function
because now what we're trying to do is
we're trying to find
not the value of a particular policy but
the optimal policy
is epsilon times b max where b max is an
upper bound
on the value function and um
and so um is bounded by the following
so you can say you're going to get an
epsilon error times v max when the
amount of data you have
scales is the following now you sort of
have an epsilon squared
error here like what we saw for the
fitted q evaluation
um gamma again is the discount factor
this is holding under some important
assumptions
so this is assuming that your function
space itself
can contain optimal policy so q star
this is your function space like your
function approximator so q star lies
here
and then this is where um we see one of
the common overlap assumptions and this
type of overlap assumption
i think it was maybe originally proposed
by remy munoz in 2003.
but what this is saying here is that if
it is possible
under some policy to have
um a distribution so let's say you
follow some policy and you reach some
state actions with non-zero probability
versus this is your behavior policy so
this is like the
density of
s a under your behavior policy
what this is saying is that that ratio
is bounded
now for someone who hasn't looked at
these quite as much that might initially
seem like a little bit of a surprising
idea um but the way that i find it
helpful to think about
is to say well imagine that you had kind
of a
uniform density over states and actions
and you had very very small probability
in many states and actions
then this you know this kind of usa
could be extremely small
so one over in usa could be um
you know just incredibly large and what
we can see in this case
is that the amount of data that we need
is scaling
linearly with c and so that means that
um if it turns out that
your sort of behavior policy doesn't
cover
some parts of the state action space
where it would be feasible to visit that
under a different policy then your error
bound might be very large
yes good question so the overlap well
yeah the i the over the question it's a
good question the overall
question is whether the overlap c should
depend on the future space
f yes to some extent i mean this is a
really interesting point because i think
um
the if if it is the k you can always
imagine kind of cheating right and like
saying there's only a single state and
then everything's in the same state so
you have perfect overlap
the problem there is that probably your
q star doesn't lie in f
um and your bellman backup error is
probably also large
and so you'd have this sort of um you
wouldn't have realizability
um and probably completeness and so
there's sort of this trade-off there
between like
you could kind of cheat and make a
function space which is less expressive
and kind of coarser
and then it's easier to achieve overlap
but then you're sort of
pushing that error into your function
approximation error because you
shouldn't be able to get like if
everything is the same single state you
can just have
a much smaller policy class as you
expect that optimal policy to be much
smaller
but it's a great question it is sort of
there's really interesting questions
over like
model specification in these cases
so just in terms of what these are
typically called
um this sort of projection of the
bellman error
keeping you in the original function
space or keeping you in a related
function space is often called
completeness
um realizability often refers to the
fact that
we um the optimal value function itself
state action value function lies in your
space
and this overlap assumption that's being
used here is this concentratability
coefficient
which comes from a line of papers from
the past and i'll have a couple
references to those later
emma um in this result
it seems that the function said f is
finite
is it true um yes
it's a good point so i think well i
think in this case and i don't know if
nan's on the line i think here
f does have to be finite probably i
suspect one can relax are just
like finite bc dimension um
but i think in this case they're
assuming that there's you know the
cardinality of the function space that
you're considering is finite
yeah some sort of complexity measure of
f
exactly the coordinate problem
that that's my assumption and one of our
other works we have sort of a bc
like dimension there another question is
uh do you remember i think none
and others had a paper but they were
arguing that this dependence
on c is unavoidable
in a way this shouldn't be really hard
to see right so if you're complaining
about that
you have this dependence on c in this
bond
uh and that seems unfortunate we should
also ask ourselves whether
you can do better than this it's a good
point i don't remember i think they do
are
i think you're correct i'd have to go
back and look at the details i think
what i would argue and we'll get back to
later
is um i think in many cases we will not
have
overlap or complete overlap for any
possible policy
and i think in some ways you know the
function here is same for any
distribution that's reachable it's not
just the optimal policy
and you would hope and we have some work
and some other people been thinking
about this too
of when you have less restrictive
overlap assumptions either can you do
the best possible with available data
or as long as your optimal policy is
covered
is that sufficient um
i also want to highlight that uh nan and
one of his students have a more recent
very recent i think a couple weeks ago
um paper arguing that maybe you don't
need this complete
completeness assumption uh so maybe
realizability is sufficient
so this is certainly a really active
area to get um continued
better results and less restrictive
assumptions for the setting
uh good question from someone is there
some way of making sure we have enough
samples from each state action pair
um you know randomized control trials or
they're
if you're if you have a small state
space often people do just through
randomization to make sure they have
coverage
i think in most realistic data sets
that's not always possible
and certainly as you start to get into
continuous state spaces
then we have to make some sort of
smoothness assumptions to imagine having
that type of coverage
now you could also use those are kind of
the model based in the model free um
another thing we could do is do
important sampling so important sampling
or weighted doubly
robust type methods can also be used i
mentioned before that because of the
variance
taking a max over a bunch of is
estimators can be
quite problematic but on the other hand
it can depend on the setting so these
estimators tend to be particularly high
variance if the horizon is long
if you have very short horizons if
you're looking at like engagement
metrics or things like that
sometimes these the variances are too
bad um
and i'll i'll talk about an interesting
case in this later
a couple of interesting cases so one
thing that i've been really interested
in over the last few years and
as one of the potential objectives is
thinking about sort of structural risk
minimization for reinforcement learning
um in this batch setting and the idea
being like we have all these different
policy classes or value function classes
or models we could use
how do we pick among them and how do we
pick among them in a way where we have
some assurances in the generalization
performance of the resulting policy
and so what i have been interested in
and together with some wonderful
colleagues is to think about bounds that
would look something like the following
where not only would they sort of be
finite sample bounds that would give us
assurances on the
performance of the policy before we
deploy it but that they somehow sort of
intuitively
should depend on like the size of the
function class we're considering
and that could give us a way to start
thinking about like model selection in
these scenarios
so this is the type of result that i was
interested in um
and i think there's been sort of a lot
of limitations to
i think most prior work has not sort of
achieved this i think um
important sampling style bounds which
are often useful don't typically
consider the structure of the space
um and i think that you know kernel
based methods often need samples that
are
exponential in the input state dimension
the fitted q a
iteration bounds some of which i just
mentioned often require this additional
realizability
and these bounds on like an inherent
film and error and the problem is
is that often you just don't know what
your function approximation error is
so it can be hard to know what that will
be i think there's also some really
interesting recent work and there's more
than i've
mentioned here kind of thinking of like
some optimization techniques and primal
dual
um some of those still have pretty
similar dependencies or
are quite challenging computationally
okay so one thing that you might argue
is to say well maybe it's going to be
really hard to get generalization
guarantees on policy performance
maybe what we want to do is just sort of
get some good in class policy someone
gives you a policy space like during
policy search or policy gradient
and you just want to do this for the
offline setting um and so then be able
to return something that we think works
pretty well
and sort of interestingly i think of
policy search policy gradient as being
probably the most successful empirical
approaches for reinforcement learning
um but i think there's been relatively
little success
on doing this direct policy optimization
in the batch setting and i think one of
the challenges is that
you kind of get this mismatch in state
distributions
and that often can be really hard in
terms of variance
and empirically one of the papers that's
been very influential sort of
approach the state action distribution
this match by just correcting for one
step
so i guess before i go on for that i
will mention i think it's a really
interesting issue that like in the
tabular setting
you only need to correct for one step
but when we start to think about
function approximation that doesn't
always work
and so the idea that um one of the one
ideas for ducklings the nerve paper that
my student yalu led and together with
some colleagues from msr
is to leverage the sort of stationary
important sampling ratios that i
mentioned before
and use those inside of the policy
gradient
and so the nice aspect so now we're
trying to correct not just prove the
difference in actions between
policy the behavior policy and the
policy our current policy and policy
gradient
but we're also trying to correct for the
fact that we would reach different
states
and so this was the first result that we
knew of that could provably converge to
a local solution
in the entirely batch offline setting
there's been a lot of off policy
um policy gradient work but most of it
still assumes that you're continuing to
collect data
and one of the things that we found
interesting here is that if you're in
the fully batch setting there was
sort of less results and the thing that
i want to highlight here is that
this is sort of this fairly small
problem cart pull but
what you can see here is that this is
the behavior policy
this is the performance of the the
policy you actually have data from
and again the nice thing here you can
see is that if we use that data and do
policy gradient on it
um we can actually sort of there's this
hidden much much better policy in the
data
so um here the x-axis is just the amount
of policy gradient steps we've done
and so again it's a little bit like the
magic results of just i think it's
really
in many cases being sample efficient uh
can
be really really helpful in terms of
better leveraging the existing
variability in the data
in order to uncover kind of these latent
gem
policies that might be present
so that's one thing that provides sort
of the local convergence to a policy
um and i think that i'll highlight here
there's some
really interesting open questions too
about um
where long policy gradients do you stop
um
if you can't execute these policies in
practice
so i just said maybe you know maybe
that's kind of quite far away from a
structural risk minimization type
objective
maybe we can kind of get a little bit
closer to that and say something like
well maybe again we have some classic
policies
we want to compare sort of regret
measure we want to say
you're going to do your procedure you're
going to select some policy so we have
some policy to
some approach to select a policy and i
want to compare the policy you picked
based on your procedure um for this data
versus the best thing we could have done
and again maybe i want that error to
sort of scale with some
some measure of the the hardness of the
policy
so um together with shin queen me and
stefan weiger
we have the first result that i know of
in this case where it is a direct
function
of sort of a measure of the complexity
of the class
and in terms of time i'm not going to go
through this in detail but i'm happy to
talk about it offline
um but we do this for a restricted
policy class so we we're doing it for
what we call when to treat policies
which are like when to stop um policies
but then you also get to make not just a
binary decision of when to stop
but then what to do when you stop so for
example you could imagine
what type of hiv treatment do you start
and then you
decide when to commence that treatment
and i think sort of the interesting
thing with this is that
i think it connects to the sort of
econometrics and statistics communities
a bit
so it leverages the idea of doubly
robustness um it leverages
prior work on um these kind of advantage
decompositions of the value function
that both susan murphy and sean kakade
have developed
um and and says well what if we're doing
this in the purely offline case
and then can we use some of these new
ideas from econometrics um
to sort of estimate these things fairly
efficiently
and i think again these sort of
orthogonal and double machine learning
ideas could be really interesting to
further
explore here and nathan callus and
others have also been been thinking a
lot about that
so just highlight again that um i think
this is now a regret measure so we're
not looking at mean squared error we're
looking at what is the policy that is
returned
and how much you know how close is that
to the optimal policy that you could
have returned in your set
so lower is better and what you can see
here
is that our approach not surprisingly is
at the bottom and what you can see is
that
it gets sort of better and better with
more data but also
uh it it does that much faster than an
ipw which is essentially important
sampling
and you can also see that like fitted q
is kind of
sort of more stat flat because it's
going to have some fundamental bias
so even with more data it may not
continue to get better
so again i just want to highlight that
this double machine learning efficiency
area is a really interesting area for
future work
all right i'm going to pause there for a
second um and see if there are any
questions
but that kind of brings us through um
kind of up to a lot of the current work
not i haven't included everything over
the last year and some of that i'll
reference in the next part
um of the types of techniques that
people have been looking at for
evaluation and optimization and i think
the optimization area
has had a huge amount of algorithmic
work match of which has had really nice
empirical
successes but i think our understanding
of the theory there is much
um in much earlier stages
so emma in in the slide you had
realizability and completeness you said
that some recent
very recent briefings suggest that
completeness may not be needed
what do you mean may not be needed
i have not um so thanks so much for the
question i
i'll redirect that to man um i i have
not went through the paper
really recently uh or i have not read
through the paper but i had heard from
um one of my i heard from nan and one of
my colleagues that they had recently
uh added that new work so i'm excited to
read it
all right well if there's other
questions feel free to ask so let's just
return to kind of what the overview was
we've sort of talked about tasks
assumptions and evaluation criteria and
what i want to do with the last part of
our time is to say let's think about
some of those assumptions
and um an evaluation criteria and
both whether or not those are reasonable
um and whether what we can do when some
of those might be violated
as well as you know should we be hopeful
about being able to kind of leverage
existing variability in data
and actually uncover things that are
better
so again i said to these standard
assumptions of kind of overlap
and no confounding or sequential
ignorability um
are very common i'll start up and just
sort of again illustrate what overlap
means um because i find that really
helpful intuitively
so imagine that we have a case where we
just have sort of a bandit setting and
we have three different
we can think of our three arms as being
like antibiotics mechanical ventilation
and vasopressors and in our behavior
policy
or in the policy you want to evaluate
maybe we give mechanical ventilation
more
a little bit less antibiotics than that
suppressors
um and imagine that in the data that was
used to
gather the behavior data the
the antibiotics were given a lot more
mechanical ventilation was similar
and vass oppressor was similar to but
both of those second a little bit less
so you could imagine that we would have
seen all three actions it would be
completely reasonable for us to use this
data to evaluate
all you know the desired policy
but it could be that nobody ever gives
vasopressors
to people in this in this state it might
be too risky
um it might be that there are other
complications and so um they're
essentially we just don't have overlap
like we can't
evaluate the performance of the policy
we want to evaluate
this one um
because um we've never tried vast
oppressors so we just don't know how
well they do
now i feel like when we look at it this
way maybe it sounds super obvious
that overlap would be violated and of
course you couldn't use that
but i think in reality this problem is
often much more subtle because of this
problem that we don't often have
a model for how decisions were made in
the data so
it may be really hard to get that sort
of underlying knowledge that oh yes
you know no emergency care physician
would ever prescribe this here
because blah blah blah you know um and
so when we don't have some of that
domain knowledge
much of which might be implicit then we
may think sort of we have
overlap when we don't now there's
actually
um well first of all i'd say there's a
lot of work historically which is
assumed overlap this is almost always
assumed
but i think in many cases many
observational data settings it won't
necessarily be true
um and i also think that a lot of real
data sets won't necessarily have
complete random exploration but they may
have some variability that we could hope
to leverage
in order to get better policies so um
why is this bad so you know there are a
lot of assumptions i've said that
sometimes you can sort of ignore
model bias maybe sometimes assuming
things are mark off when they're not
isn't that bad
the problem with assuming overlap when
it's not is that often the
things like important sampling require
overlap
and people use important sampling
estimators as if they're giving a real
unbiased estimator of the policy and
that you can often get confidence
intervals over those
and so when people think that you have
an estimator which is highly reliable
it's really giving you a lower bound if
you don't have overlap
it can be really misleading and so let
me just give sort of a hypothetical
example
you can imagine there might be some
scenarios under which
you would never uh like give a certain
medication to
to some people that are very sick um and
a lot of those patients might have you
know really bad outcomes kind of
regardless of what you do because
they're already really sick
we don't want your kind of policy
optimization technique to be able to
sort of cheat
by just not having overlap in those
cases and giving out
other actions also you would never do
for those very sick patients
which are never taken um because that
could basically make you
over competent in the policy that you
have
whereas if you really deployed it when
you got to those really sick patient
care
and you're making these recommendations
they actually might be much worse than
what people were doing before
so um these things can be really
challenging when we sort of assume
there's overlap when there's not
so one way we've been sort of thinking
about it and i think a number of people
um of last couple years have been
thinking about this problem of sort of
over
optimism which often can be caused by
lack of overlap
um it's what we've been sort of
centering towards is a different
objective is well how could what's the
best we can do with what we've got
so if we imagine that there's some um
data distribution that you have access
to
what we'd like to be able to do is try
to find the best policy that is covered
or that has overlap
with your behavior policy and i think
this gets to one of the questions that
was raised before of like
you know what can we what can we do with
with the data that we have or
what what if you don't have full overlap
and
the idea that we had is a pretty simple
one um
which is to be pessimistic for parts of
the state action space where you have
insufficient overlap
now this algorithm that that we have in
submission right now is a model free
algorithm and i'll talk more about some
other approaches in just a second
i do want to highlight that most of the
recent work that's been trying to tackle
this problem has also been model free
but a number of them have some
limitations so we
um go through it in detail now due to
time but
we can come up with sort of a couple
small toy mvps which i always find
really illustrative um when i'm trying
to understand a problem
that illustrate why some of the previous
approaches even though they're trying
they're aiming to be more conservative
that they can still be overly optimistic
in some of these settings and that also
includes things like
bear and bcq and some of these other
ones that are
have been really targeted towards deep
reinforcement learning in the offline
case and trying to be more conservative
due to sort of
over optimism bias that can happen in
part due to lack of overlap
and the key idea that we had is to say
well you know imagine that you could
sort of estimate
your state action distribution that's
covered in your data
and you sort of have a simple filter
about whether or not you have sufficient
coverage or not
and then when you're doing bellman
backups you're only allowed to do sort
of
building backups over parts of the space
that has
you know sufficient overlap and outside
of that you end up sort of inserting a
pessimistic bias
and one of the nice things here is that
the bounds that we get
end up being sort of the best with
respect to the policy that is
within the sort of supported set which i
think in these cases is really the best
you could hope for
um and because you aren't necessarily
i'm not saying our balance with the
titus but i think this type of objective
is helpful to think about because it's
saying like if you have a good policy
within the data that you've collected so
far
you would like to be able to recover it
and so can we talk about how close you
are to that
and if that's an optimal policy that's
great um
but if it's just a really good policy
then um
then that's also helpful and that allows
us to avoid
the strong concentrated ability
assumptions that have been made before
in some ways we can think of it as
instead of just requiring
concentratability and overlap
we're saying you are only going to
search over a policy space
that that maintains sufficient overlap
and one of the nice things here is on
sort of an empirical side is again we
can find things that um
kind of are more safe when they're
generalizing and so
when you actually deploy them on the
x-axis here is actually sort of you know
rewards
if you were to run this so this is if
you were to deploy it in the real
environment
that um by being sort of more
conservative you get things that um
are more solid and then when you deploy
then you actually get better performance
okay so this is model free approaches
and i think some of the theory here is
nice
um hey but that was i want to highlight
here of like
why be model free you know maybe with me
being a using a model might be better
and i think there's been some really
beautiful work over the last couple
years
by people showing where models can be
provably better than be model free
in the online setting for reinforcement
learning
and so given these sorts of results you
might wonder hey if this is what's
happening for online learning then maybe
there are cases where provably model
based approaches are better
um in the offline case and you might
imagine if you have strong parametric
assumptions of the models that would
almost definitely be true but maybe it's
true in some sort of general sense
and so there's been several different
papers concurrent to ours i think all of
these have come out this summer
on archive um that are thinking about
doing a very similar type of idea to
what we were doing
in model-free in a model-based way
and essentially in these approaches um
this is
the high level um they're learning
dynamics models
and they're trying to estimate the
uncertainty over those dynamics models
and then they penalize parts of the
state action space where those model
uncertainty is high and so for those of
you that are familiar with like
um the you know upper confidence-based
optimism
this is exactly flipping that and so
instead of being optimistic under
uncertainty we're going to be
pessimistic under uncertainty
and then we can inject that into our
planning algorithms
so that the resulting value function of
policies we compute
should be conservative and therefore
avoid parts of the state space where we
may have very little overlap
uh and empirically some of these have
really really promising results on sort
of the d4rl
benchmark tasks um i think that there's
still even further room to do more
theoretical analyses and to better
characterize um where the model based
approaches
good or bad and what type of finance
sample guarantees might they have and
i'll adjust to some of our
finite sample guarantees um but i think
in general these types of approaches are
very promising
i don't think the the question of um how
to best behave
with your limited data coverage is
solved yet
and i also think that both our method
and these methods
they're all sensitive to
misspecification if you've got the the
function approximator class wrong um
that will directly lead to error or
regret
or might right you might have a bunch of
classroom but you might still be able to
represent the optimal policy
so i think those sorts of questions are
still very much open
okay um so the next thing
um i'm going to talk about is that sort
of talks about a line of different types
of works
that are thinking about this overlap
assumption um
and the next thing i wanted to talk
about a little bit of
is sequential ignorability so again just
to go back
um in sequential ignorability we assume
that all state variables that we use to
inform treatment decisions are known or
recorded in the data
but in observational data uh this might
particularly if the behavior policy is
known
this might be violated so you could
imagine when you talk to your doctor
you may have a long conversation you may
tell them that like
you know you've recently quit smoking or
you've lost your job or like there's
different stressful situations or maybe
you come in and you look
um like you've just come from a run so
they know that you're exercising a lot
or
you know there might be different things
that are providing additional sources of
information
that the doctor is using to help inform
and diagnose
your condition and make treatment
recommendations
and so if there are these and those
variables may or may not be recorded
directly in the electronic medical
record system
now my personal belief is that many of
those variables at least in the u.s
might be recorded because for better or
worse there's a very strong
um suing culture in parts of america and
that means that
you have to be able to be prepared for
potential lawsuits if one makes
bad decisions and so an implication of
that is i think that the documentation
burden
is probably pretty high to be able to
justify decisions retroactively
and there are good things and bad things
about that but i think that what that
means empirically is that probably
inside of um
the written notes that doctors make
there's probably a lot of these sort of
variables that are being recorded but in
the standards for electronic medical
record systems that are already sort of
coded
and made quantitative
some of that stuff may be missing in
fact i think a lot of it is missing
and so this problem may be something
that goes away a little bit as we start
to get better natural language
processing of those notes
but i think there are many situations
where this kind of unobserved
compounding
can again be sort of interfering with
the data quality and can mean that um
if we assume that you know the physician
was always giving these type of
recommendations that in fact they might
not have been they might have only be
giving this to like
young pregnant women and you know men
over 70 were getting something totally
different now age
and gender are things we'd probably see
but there might be other factors in
there
um they're being used that are not being
recorded and again can lead to erroneous
inference
so this is something that i think
there's been again growing interest of
um there's some really nice historical
work on this from
um the statistics and biostats and
epidemiology community
within the ai community people like
judea pearl
and vera mom use me and a number of
others have been thinking about the
problems of
founding the latent variables for a long
time
recently there's been work kind of in
this from the rl perspective
um i think some of this work assumes
that you're kind of in a palm dp
and you can identify this sort of
confounding over time as you get more
um states and observations and actions
um some of the work makes very very
minimal assumptions
over what potential confounding could
happen and
may simply assume that you know that
everything is a probability um
distribution and that can give you some
useful information for balance and some
work sort of things about how
confounding can be um limit have limited
impact on the resulting reward
variables so one thing that we've been
thinking about is a sort of a little bit
orthogonal to this but based on some
work from
uh some ideas from the single time step
setting um
is to think about confounding as having
bounded influence on the decisions
so for example maybe if someone comes in
and they're wearing
um yoga wear and like they see and they
talk a lot about exercise
maybe i push them to something that's
sort of like a behavioral intervention
instead of a drug intervention
as a physician perhaps right but but you
know if they still have really high
blood pressure and they have a lot of
risk factors that are all fully
observable
maybe it doesn't completely change my
probabilities of making treatment
decisions maybe it just nudges them a
little bit
and so this type of model is kind of is
known as bounded confounding
um and it's been thought of for a long
time including for
you know focused on single time step
decisions where the idea is that the
amount that a hidden confounder so this
is a hidden confounder
the amount that that could change which
decision i make
so here's two different hidden
compounders u and u prime
the amount that this could perturb my
likelihood to
pick one action versus the other in
terms of as a behavior policy or as a
decision maker
is bounded so it can't be wildly
different
um so that says you know whether they're
wearing yoga pants and talk a lot about
exercise maybe i still mostly prescribe
them you know
a blood pressure medication but it
slightly increases the likelihood that i
would perhaps
suggest some behavioral modifications
and
so i think this is a really interesting
model because it's sort of in some ways
we can think of this as sensitivity
analysis
it's saying like imagine that your
behavior policy is a little bit wrong
um and it might be a little bit
influenced or you know some
some sort of fixed amount um different
than what you can kind of observe
but it's not going to be wildly
different under those scenarios can we
still get bounce
on off policy evaluation or even off
policy optimization in a way that we
think we might have some assurances
so unfortunately even under this case
you know if if you have this bounded
confounding if you have
it for enough time steps it can still
lead to sort of an exponential
uncertainty over your estimation um
but one of the things that we did is
showed that if you think of there being
maybe a limited amount of time steps on
which there is confounding
in particular if there might just be
just be one for example maybe you
prescribe a policy and then that sort of
executed by people more
then we can get some uh scenarios where
even under some limited amounts of
confounding
you could still uncover that one policy
is better than the other in terms of its
value
so we looked at a couple different
simulated domains based on health care
settings
and what you can see in these scenarios
is for example
here this is showing you sort of how
much confounding you have and if you
have a ton of confounding then
eventually you have no idea what the
behavior policy is and it's very hard to
make inferences
um because there could be so much
compounding things could really really
change
but we could see here is that this
policy here which is
with antibiotics that act uh given some
amount of compounding we can still
derive upper and lower bounds on the
performance of the policy
that tell us that it's still better than
without antibiotics
and you can see that it's a more naive
approach which could be something like
just thinking about your behavior policy
having some epsilon error and then kind
of multiplying that for the number of
time decisions that you have
and not we use several different
constraints in in the optimization
process we do
that this would sort of not make it that
you're you can only be sure for a much
smaller amount of confounding
and so again this sort of just provides
us with a way of being
more robust to the failure of some of
these assumptions
by carefully um designing the
optimization process
this has worked with uh uh rompton
caramadi as
steve yadlovsky and hong uh namco
i think there's a there's a lot of work
to be done in terms of the unobserved
confounding
um i think some of the recent work
that's thinking about proxy variables
and places where you can identify things
and more palm dp like approaches is very
promising
when those assumptions hold um but i
think even just thinking about when
these sort of sensitivity analyses are
reasonable is helpful
um sort of just two for their last few
minutes i guess i'll just say
a couple quick things one is that um in
terms of the evaluation criteria i've
talked about so far
i talked about sort of scalar rewards
and empirical accuracy etc
but i think one of the really exciting
things that we're moving to in
reinforcement learning and anka talked
about this a lot
is the idea of reward functions being
more complex
and so i think in um in many cases we
care about things like risk sensitivity
we can care about constraints for safety
reasons we care about constraints for
fairness reasons
um and in many cases we may actually
have sort of a pareto front
of different objectives that we care
about and
particularly in the batch rl setting
that we have this opportunity to sort of
show how different policies would
compare across this space
so i think that that's a really
interesting direction
for considering in the bachelor setting
um the final thing i want to just end
with is whether we should be hopeful
um so i think there's been a lot of
really amazing successes about
meditation learning um and in some ways
bachelorelle is imitation learning in
the sense that we're both assuming often
that you have sort of this
amount of data to start with and you
could hope to
imitate the best policy in that data or
imitate the policy that was used to
generate that data
like in invitation learning or what
we're hoping to do is something actually
more ambitious which is to
outperform the behavior policy
so essentially we'd like to say we've
got this old data
can we only just match pi b or can we do
better
so i just want to give you two reasons
to be optimistic
the first is the way i first got
interested in this problem which is
um through my work on a fractions game
where kids
um manipulate spaceships to try to learn
about fractions
um and the policies here like what sort
of activities do they get at which time
point
and what we had in this case is we had a
lot of prior data and we wanted to learn
this new policy
and um the interesting thing in this
case is that by doing reinforcement
learning we could actually learn a
policy offline that increased student
persistence by 30
and it was also 30 better both than
random
and better than sort of the expert
policy from before
so that sort of illustrates why in some
cases there might be a lot of things
left on the table when you do have quite
random data
but i think even more optimistic than
that is some really nice very recent
work that just came out in ai stats
about a week ago
um from finale joshi velaz and joe
futuma and michael hughes
and here it's just observational data i
believe this is from the mimic data set
um and they're looking at hypertension
and they had a really interesting
approach here where they're sort of
doing this model based
upon dp model based approach um so
that's kind of the policy class they're
considering
but they're using um an estimator to
compare amongst those policies
that makes very little assumptions it's
an important sort of
an important sampling approach estimator
uh
and and they also have some other really
interesting things here about
interpretability so the key thing that i
just want to mention is sort of the take
home which is if you look at sort of the
actual performance of the policy so this
is like the policy
in the real data set um you can see that
they're able to find
both value function methods and their
method can find something that looks
substantially better
than the the policy that's being used
for patients right now
and so when i saw that i thought that
was really optimistic because it seemed
like
uh and you can see here it's not just um
you can also get confidence intervals
over these type of estimates as well but
i think that
it's really great to see cases where
there is a natural variability in the
data that we have access to
that we could leverage in order to get
much better policies
even if we it is even if it isn't
feasible for us to actually run online
experiments
and so with that i'll conclude um i
think that to me
one of the big challenges that we all
face when we're trying to figure out our
research directions is do we want to do
things that we think are
more applied and towards problems that
we care deeply about for me those are
things like education healthcare
um and versus some really incredible
beautiful theory
um and out and new types of algorithms
and one of the things that i think is so
exciting about the batch offline
rl setting is that it's exactly this
nexus of the two where there's so many
applications that could really benefit
from it
and there's so many important open
questions that we still need to tackle
so with that i'll conclude
thanks um
do you have some questions
so yeah you you talked a lot about this
overlap and the lack of overlap or
what can you do uh
do we have an any any lower bonds for
this setting
so i imagine that uh you collect some
data there is some underlying and
beeping maybe you're making assumptions
that
data really comes from whatnot and
uh and then you can ask the question
given this
data how well can an argument do
and what sort of algorithms would
achieve that
lower bond but it has to be a
non-uniform larva
right because otherwise the overlap is
going to come in and whatnot
right uh so here the overlap usually
refers to how much overlap
that is uh between the distribution
induced by the policy you're shooting
for
uh to estimate its value on like this
cover
uh versus the uh the distribution that
was generating the data
but normally it's even worse than that
it's like the variable right like
you're choosing the policy so
do you have anything a sense of this so
you quickly showed a result
of a new paper that is under submission
is that paper out
yeah um for us yeah we've said it we had
it's an archive um for the one we have
for model it's a it's a model free
approach i think the model based ones
empirically have very nice
performance um but i think the model
free ones there's some nice theory there
i
i think um i don't think we know that
yet i think it's a good question
i think the original concentration and
overlap assumptions were really quite
strong because it was not just about
the policy the final policy that you
care about but you sort of had to have
coverage for any
distribution you might be achieving any
distribution you might be able to sort
of
reach under any policy and i think part
of the reason for that is
you're doing sort of a series of um
dynamic programming style of backups and
so for each of those policies they need
to be covered
um and so you might have to sort of
support many policies
um outside of the one that you care
about at the end
and if you just knew the one at the end
an important sampling would have that
covered
um even if a dynamic programming method
would go through some policies that
weren't
but i think um i don't think we know
about sort of lower bounds in terms of
what what are the best results in terms
of overlap we could hope to expect
again based on your conversation i'll
look back at nan's
uh paper from a year ago to see the
lower bounds there my guess is that the
lower bounds will be pretty awful that
you could construct on
even so awful little mdps where there's
like one really great state and if you
don't even something like um
a chain type mdp you know it's very hard
particularly under like
a uniform policy to see those high
rewards and that's where you need to
spend time but maybe you should
aim for an instance dependent lower bond
and instance adaptivity because
otherwise
maybe as you say everything is going to
be
just look very very dark
uh i think yeah and dylan just brought
up a point
saying that he thinks that man's paper
mostly it
shows it's qualitatively required but it
doesn't um
say that the particular functional
dependence that we see right now of the
overlap inside of the bounds is needed
um or if there might not be other that
you know better alternative definitions
of overlap
um yeah that might be yeah like uh maybe
you
you didn't see that because obviously
you were
speaking but there were some questions
related to this
in the chat and i pointed people to a
recent paper
by uh mangdy
um and uh yaki duon
student of mangby uh they're talking
about
uh all four dc uh
for linear function approximation it
just policy evaluation but
you know like you you see part of these
issues there
and they point out that uh it's
basically about the underlying covenants
metrics
uh not really about uh overlap per se so
that kind of
what happens if you have functional
approximation
and the nice thing is that they have
minimax opportunity design so they have
lower bonds and upper bounds
uh that show that the quantity does that
appear in their bonds
uh already have to be dead but again
this is worst case
and when uh i'm seeing these uh
optimistic results
uh then clearly uh those happen
because we are not in a worst case
scenario
uh but there maybe there is a way of
understanding
uh how uh how far you can push
uh results on an instance by instance
basis so you might require that the
algorithm universe case
is uh pretty good and amongst all those
algorithms you can ask like how well any
argument that does
pretty well in the worst case can do on
a particular instance
so this way uh you're restricting the
set of variables so you don't
arrive at vacuous results and then you
can ask like okay how complicated is an
instance for an argument that is knee
reverse case optimal
and then i would think that
it should be possible to answer these
questions but
yeah i don't don't know the answers to
this
yeah so yeah i don't i haven't read that
paper a 19-hertz student
um my guess there is that like the model
based in the model 3
methods that i mentioned it will still
require assumptions on
realizability and sort of lack of bottom
specification which i think that um
empirically i think that's a big deal
for a lot of the applications that we
we are that many people that that we
could hope to use bachelor l for
now how serious the assumptions are i
mean like if you load this blow up
of the approximation error by a factor
of square root of d
then it seems that realizability is not
such a big deal
uh i mean okay maybe skeleton
is a big deal but that's the best that
you can do
uh in general but uh
i don't think that in a nutshell that
realizability would be a showstopper
i think that those are just initial
designs that people are going to extend
these to
the unrealizable setting yeah i think
it'll get
it'll get tighter i mean i think some of
the bounds that we have right now for
lack of realizability ends up
essentially having you know
constant terms or um and i think
um i think for many of the cases that i
personally am most interested in like we
really need finite example guarantees
of an accurate lower bound before we
would make a decision about whether to
deploy something um
and so like constants matter in those
cases are having
sort of um estimates that we think are
very solid
um and so i don't i don't think the
theoretical work and the model free of
the model based approaches have come to
that part yet if one's in a setting
where
it's not quite as high stakes i think
it's completely reasonable
but i agree with you that maybe the
bounce will get much tighter um and i
think
a lot of this there's been so much work
in the last year or two that i suspect
people may be even working on it now
okay
and were you referring to a discussion
in discord yeah i wasn't monitoring that
during my talk but i'll look it up later
so on the discord we try to answer all
the questions that
came up and i don't really see any open
questions
i think that the the open question that
uh
was left unanswered after the first talk
was
over what's your intuition of what to
use when
but i guess at the beginning of uh this
talk you you try to answer that a little
bit
yeah and if anybody has follow-up
questions feel free to send me an email
or i'll be on discord and others too
so i have a question about ignorability
uh i'm always struggling to understand
this notation
i have to read all the definitions and
everything every time
but at one point i decided that
ignorability
is this assumption that you have to
record everything
that the decisions that you want to
argue about in the future
are based on in your data set and if you
did that then you are fine and
the ignorability is just like some form
of description of this is this
is this correct that's how i think of it
yeah that like all of the information
you'd ever need
to cut it's why decisions are made now
or for the rest of your trajectory
are captured okay then it doesn't matter
whether you're in an mvp or a prom dp or
whatnot
it is just that uh there shouldn't be
any
hidden information that was used and
that could be
correlated with the outcome in some
sneaky way
uh that you don't know about right yes
and i guess that and that's a
an important distinction that it has to
it it's affecting future actions or
future states or future rewards
those are things we care about i guess
the the assumption that i
remember is a little bit stronger than
ignorability because
uh maybe there is some information that
you can ignore
because that information is not
impacting the future outcomes so then
like why care
but in general it's really hard to know
so it's
if you want to be safe then you should
just
uh include all the information uh
that is impacting uh the
decision variables that you want to
reason about
in the future right
okay yeah yeah okay
okay all right
okay all right thanks everybody
see you tomorrow yeah um see you soon um
i think in half an hour next door oh
yeah next time thanks